Sometimes, it's hard to tell
the difference between Easter
eggs and clues that video games share a
universe. Just so happens that, sometimes,
they're both. Let's take a closer look at some
video game universes with startling connections.
The Uncharted and The Last of Us series are two
of PlayStation's biggest and best first-party
exclusives. But did you know that one is actually
a sequel to the other? Well… kind of, at least.
In Uncharted 3, there's a
newspaper with a headline reading:
"Scientists are still struggling to understand
deadly fungus" — an intentional reference to
The Last of Us. At the time of Uncharted
3's release, however, The Last of Us had
yet to be formally announced, and that newspaper
wasn't actually supposed to remain in the game.
Naughty Dog's Neil Druckmann
candidly told Kotaku :
"We just completely forgot
about it. We screwed up."
Fortunately for them, they
ended up getting away with it
without spoiling their then-upcoming announcement.
"What took you so long?"
Japanese video game designer Hideo Kojima
likes to fill his games with Easter eggs.
And that's why his graphic adventure
game Policenauts offers plenty of clues
that it shares a universe with
Snatcher and Metal Gear Solid.
Policenauts has tons of Snatcher references. In
addition to a few direct cameos from the cyberpunk
adventure game, there's a Snatcher calendar in Jun
Ishida's office, and Victor Jurgens uses the same
brand of sunscreen found in both games. There's
also a Snatcher target in the police station's
shooting range that plays a remixed version of the
game's "Pressure of Tension" song when it's hit.
In Metal Gear Solid, you can find two promotional
posters for Policenauts in the Nuclear Warhead
Storage Building, with a third popping up
in Metal Gear Solid 2: Sons of Liberty.
Drebin 893 drinks a soda called is named
after the addictive drug in Policenauts,
and there's even a bar named after
Solid Snake in Policenauts' Old L.A.
And that's just scratching the surface
of the cosmic clues — happy hunting!
The Red Faction series from Volition and
THQ tells the story of the titular faction's
resistance against the oppressive reign
of the nefarious Ultor Corporation, set
amidst a sci-fi future of dystopian proportions.
Meanwhile, the Saints Row series from Volition and
THQ — along with latter day publisher Deep Silver
— chronicles the story of the Third Street Saints,
a street gang turned global crime organization who
face rival criminals and corrupt law enforcement
during their ongoing slapstick quest for
domination. While the first game in the series
was a relatively straightforward GTA clone,
later entities… well, they got a little wild.
"You can't kill me! My
people will avenge my death!"
"Not with a bang… but with a whimper."
As luck — and the cheeky developers
of Volition — would have it,
the events of the Red Faction series actually take
place in the future of the Saints Row universe,
and the nefarious Ultor Corporation is the link.
"The Ultor corporation has been using a secret R&D
lab to conduct unethical experiments
on the citizens of Stilwater."
In case you missed it, the episodic expansion
packs Ultor Exposed and Corporate Warfare
for Saints Row 2 are probably the most overt
references to Red Faction's big bad adversaries
in the Saints series. The first of these two
DLC packs lays the groundwork for exposing the
megacorp's seedy operations, while the second
installment offers players a chance to, quote,
"put a permanent end to Ultor's
corruption" head on. The result:
one of the craziest canonical
crossovers in video game history.
Remedy Entertainment's connected universe
is more intricate than many fans realize.
Remedy's 2010 game Alan Wake is a bizarre trip
through alternate dimensions. As the title
character searches for his missing wife, he begins
to see elements of a story he wrote coming to
life. The endings of Alan Wake and its follow-ups
left its hero's fate unclear, which has tormented
fans for years. But did you know references to
Mr. Wake have shown up in Remedy's newer titles?
Quantum Break, released in 2016, features
several callbacks to Alan Wake. For instance,
a chalkboard in the game seems to
describe events from Alan Wake.
Not only that, another Easter egg revealed
live action footage of Alan Wake himself.
Then came 2019's Control. Through
documents discovered during Control,
players learn that the game's Federal Bureau of
Control investigated the events of Alan Wake, but
unfortunately didn't find much. Footage of Alan
can also be found in a hidden area of the game.
Finally, Control's AWE expansion brought
Bureau Director Jesse Faden into conflict
with Emil Hartman, a mad psychologist
with ties to Alan and Alice Wake.
The Malaysia-inspired island of Panau is the
setting of Just Cause 2, the 2010 open world
action-adventure game from Avalanche Studios and
Eidos Interactive . It tells the continuing story
of chaotic hero Rico Rodriguez and his battle
against some of the world's craziest militant
dictators. Interestingly enough, Panau also makes
a subtle appearance in Sleeping Dogs, the Hong
Kong-based action adventure from United Front
Games and Eidos parent publisher Square Enix .
One Easter egg from Sleeping Dogs definitively
places these two games in the same universe.
If your timing and radio station are
correct, you'll hear a fun little
advertisement that shouts out the
familiar setting of Just Cause 2:
"For a relaxing getaway,
visit the island of Panau, an exotic location
where beauty and luxury are an everyday pleasure."
French video game publisher Ubisoft made
its reputation by developing some of the
most immersive open world games on the market —
games that emphasize exploration and branching
narratives over linear storytelling and
guided adventures. It's no surprise,
then, that Ubisoft would decide to set
a few of their fan-favorite franchises
in a shared universe; but the
clues aren't always up front.
Fortunately for us, the modern-day sequences of
Assassin's Creed 4: Black Flag offer some clarity.
Set in the offices of a video game development
studio known as Abstergo Entertainment — a
not-so-subtle front for Abstergo Industries,
aka the Templar Order, the Assassins' rival
faction — these sequences provide several distinct
references to Ubisoft's Watch Dogs and Far Cry 3.
For instance, the "Security Systems Presentation"
offers a blatant reference to the primary
city-wide hacking mechanic of Watch Dogs:
"Nowhere is our expertise more
apparent than in our flagship product,
'ctOS ' – a ground-breaking proprietary
security-software operating system."
Meanwhile, the Abstergo Entertainment database
entry for "Ocelot" obliquely suggests that Far
Cry 3, the video game itself, could actually
be yet another virtual construct of the Animus.
"Did I ever tell you the definition of insanity?"
The science-fiction stylings of NieR: Automata
from PlatinumGames and publisher Square Enix
seem like a far cry from the medieval
fantasy of Drakengard from Cavia Inc.
and Macrospace — but these two action-RPGs
are separated by a lengthy span of sequels
and studio changeovers, so they actually
exist squarely in the same universe.
The description of NieR: Automata on the game's
official website tells us its story takes place
in "the distant future." That future is, in
fact, a far-flung time period following the
events of Drakengard, which chronicles the dark
fantasy story of the deposed prince Caim and his
efforts to stop the malevolent Watchers from
destroying the world. Game scholars understand
the "E" ending of Drakengard — in which Caim and
his dragon pal Angelus travel across a dimensional
boundary to fight the Queen Grotesquerie in modern
day Tokyo — to be the canonical ending that leads
into the 2010 hack-and-slash RPG Nier, which is
itself a direct forerunner of NieR: Automata.
Don't worry if you're confused.
You're not the only one.
In NieR: Automata, quote, "Mankind is driven
from Earth and takes refuge on the Moon."
Now, with the full history laid out before
us, we finally understand that particular
Earth to be the alternate-history
Earth of Drakengard, known as Midgard.
With ample evidence of a UFO
conspiracy that interlinks the
background narratives of Grand Theft
Auto 5 and Red Dead Redemption 2,
it's safe to say that Rockstar Games
is no stranger to shared game worlds.
But did you know that Manhunt from Rockstar North
was also set in the GTA universe? A variety of
evidence suggests that it is: notably, the very
location of the game's controversial narrative.
Manhunt takes place within the
fictional setting of Carcer City,
a ruthless lampoon of America's Rust Belt, where
street gangs rule the night. GTA fans who paid
enough attention will probably recognize Carcer
City from one of its many subtle appearances in
the series; it's been mentioned at least once
in every Grand Theft Auto release since GTA 3,
including the Stories spinoffs
developed for handheld consoles.
"In nearby Carcer City,
a good day for order as police chief Gary
Schafer was cleared of corruption charges."
And if there was any doubt, James
Earl Cash — Manhunt's sociopathic
protagonist — appears on wanted posters
within the Grand Theft Auto universe,
most notably in locations like the Police
Department in San Andreas . Crime might not pay,
but in Rockstar's shared worlds,
it'll definitely make you famous.
With its focus on a single-player campaign,
Battlefield: Bad Company from DICE was a bit of
a departure from the tried and true formula of the
fan-favorite FPS franchise in 2008. But the game's
humorous narrative, along with its introduction of
highly destructible environments, made it a smash
hit. GameSpot called it, quote, "quite simply one
of the most fun shooters released [that] year."
DICE was also responsible for Mirror's Edge:
Catalyst, the 2016 sequel of their unique
sci-fi action platformer, also from 2008. Catalyst
expanded the story and gameplay of the original
and took a few narrative liberties in its
effort to round out the lore behind Faith
Connors and her death-defying run through The
City. DICE looked to their previous titles to
establish a "real world" element for the dystopian
future of Mirror's Edge by placing the boys from
Bad Company directly into the expanded
narrative of Catalyst via audio files.
"Did you just call Gabriel Kruger 'Gabe?'"
"Yeah. We're on a first-name
basis. It's a bromance! You know!"
Valve Corporation's legendary first-person shooter
Half-Life changed the video game industry forever
when it hit personal computers in 1998. It tells
the heart-pounding story of theoretical physicist
Gordon Freeman and his dimension-shattering
discoveries at the Black Mesa Research Facility.
And curiously enough, Black Mesa would prove to
be part of the game's connective tissue to another
Valve title, Portal, the award-winning
3D puzzle-platformer released in 2007.
Portal takes players on a wild ride
through the Aperture Science laboratories
as they try to unravel the enigmas of the
artificial intelligence known as GLaDOS
and learn for themselves that the cake
is a lie. Astute gamers will recognize
oblique clues in GLaDOS' dialogue that
reference the events of Half-Life,
along with a tongue-in-cheek
PowerPoint presentation. Furthermore,
Aperture founder Cave Johnson mentions his Black
Mesa rivals by name multiple times in Portal 2.
Whether or not industrial espionage is healthy for
business, it certainly made for one sweet spinoff.
"Cave Johnson, new owner and CEO of
Black Mesa. That's right. You've been
bought. First order of business: We're
renaming you under the Aperture brand."
Due in 2022, The Callisto Protocol is a
survival horror game set in the furthest
reaches of outer space. The game places players
in the shoes of a prisoner in Black Iron,
a prison located on Jupiter's moon Callisto.
When aliens attack the facility, it's up to
the prisoner to fight the invasion and get
out alive. Developed by Striking Distance
and directed by Dead Space co-creator
Glen Schofield, the terrifying-looking
game seems like a far cry from the setting of
PlayerUnknown's Battlegrounds. However, as a
Striking Distance rep confirmed for IGN, the two
games are actually linked by a shared universe.
In an interview with GamesRadar, Schofield said
that although a few hundred years and plenty of
space separates PUBG and The Callisto Protocol,
hardcore fans would most likely be able to pick
up on references to the wider PUBG universe
throughout the game. Schofield explained:
"We're helping PUBG Corp right now as a team of
writers, working on the lore for PUBG and its
universe. It's not going to be really deep, but
there will be little connections here and there."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one!